PROFESSOR: So we have two basic
agenda items today.
The first is to finish up
briefly our discussion of
punishment from last lecture.
And the second is to start with
the third unit of the
course, that is the unit that's
concerned not with our
status as individuals trying
to cultivate a kind of
internal harmony, nor with our
status as individuals in local
relations with others of a moral
or immoral sort, but
rather with our status as
members of a community.
And you'll remember from Plato's
Republic, the text
with which we begin and with
which we'll end the course,
that Plato sees there being a
direct parallel between the
individual and the community,
between what's mandated for
the harmonious soul on the one
hand, and what's required for
a community to stay stable
on the other.
And one of the tacit themes
that will underlie our
discussion in this final unit of
the course are the ways in
which that parallel
is manifest.
Now to some extent our
discussion of punishment
provided a microcosm
of this transition.
You'll recall that in the first
lecture on punishment we
looked at three questions.
We tried to articulate in a
fairly precise sense what we
meant by the notion of
civil punishment.
And then we looked at two
families of justification for
civil punishment.
A family of deontological or
desert oriented theories on
the one hand--
theories that look at what
somebody deserves.
And on the other hand,
we looked at some
consequentialist theories--
theories that try to justify
punishment on the basis of its
consequences.
And for each of those theories,
we asked ourselves
how reasonable the
justifications are that they
offer and what source
of behaviors do
they seem to mandate.
And here we had the same sort
of structure that we have
found throughout the course.
On the one hand, an articulation
of a principled
framework for understanding
a large segment of human
behavior that tries to lay
down rules and guiding
principles by which we ought
to structure behavior.
And on the other, we
had intuitions
about particular cases.
And we found that here, as
elsewhere, for many of you at
least, certainly for the
students in my section and for
the students in the sections
of the TAs that I've spoken
to, that there was a challenge
reconciling on the one hand,
the philosophical framework that
seemed truly compelling
and on the other hand, the
psychological factors that
seemed to be pulling us in one
direction or another with
regard to particular cases.
So what we looked out at in our
a discussion on Thursday
were some attempts to provide
systematic explorations of
some of these psychological
phenomena: factors that seemed
to exacerbate people's desire
to inflict punishment, at
least most people, most of the
time, in Western society.
And factors that tend
to mitigate it.
And we also talked a bit about
the role of moral luck in
underlying lying our responses
to punishment.
What I want to turn to in the
first part of today's lecture
is the residual question that
we had in the context of our
punishment lecture.
Namely, to look at the question
of how on the one
hand civil punishment works,
and on the other, how
punishment works in a much
more personal context.
So you'll recall that-- sorry,
I guess we don't have the
final version of these
slides up.
OK.
There was to have been a slide
here-- which is not this one--
that connected our theories of
punishment to our discussion
in Alan Kazdin.
What we have instead is an
earlier slide, where I
suggested a connection between
the work of Alan Kazdin on the
one hand and Aristotle's
Nicomachean
Ethics on the other.
You'll recall that when we were
trying to think about the
question how do we cultivate
virtue, I suggested that one
of the places to look in your
contemporary culture at the
question "how do we help people
become that which we
hope they will be?" are in
scientifically informed,
compassionate, parenting
guides.
And it is, I think, an
interesting question to ask
with respect to punishment.
So you'll recall that when we
had the slide with four kinds
of justification for punishment
in the earlier
lecture, we had on the one hand
the utilitarian and the
desert-based theory.
But we also had, at the bottom
of that slide, two motivations
for punishment that look on the
one hand at the victim and
on the other hand at the
perpetrator, and aimed somehow
to reconcile their situation.
And what those motivations for
punishment suggested is that
with respect to the victim, what
matters is restitution
and with respect to the
perpetrator, if we are truly
forward-looking, what matters
is rehabilitation.
And the question is whether
those motivations are
sufficiently forceful and
sufficiently powerful to
capture what we're
looking for from
punishment in a civil context.
It seems fairly clear that those
motivations are at least
close to sufficient in
a personal context.
And it's to that question that
Alan Kazdin's discussion in
the context of this encoding of
cultural practices in the
parenting guide that we read.
So Kazdin points out that if
your goal is something akin
you to rehabilitation, if the
goal of punishment is what
forward-looking theories
suggest, that is the changing
of future behavior on the part
on the individual who has
violated social norms in such a
way that you can predictably
expect them to behave
prosocially, then it's
incredibly important not merely
to articulate what sort
of behavior is disallowed,
but also to provide an
articulation of what sort
of behavior is desired.
"Instead," says Kazdin, "of
thinking of your child's
behavior in terms of what you
don't want, start thinking in
terms of what you do want.
When you get rid of a behavior
by rewarding its opposite, the
effects of the getting rid are
stronger and last longer than
if you punish the undesired
behavior."
And all of you had the
opportunity to think about
this structure of practice
in the opening
segment of the course.
The very idea of focusing on
what it is that you hope to
cultivate as a habit in
yourself, and then engaging in
behaviors that allow that sort
of practice to become
instinctive to you, was one of
the central lessons of the
first unit of the course.
The best way we learned to build
up a behavior that you
want is through reinforced
practice.
And Kazdin goes on to suggest,
in the context of punishment,
that punishment teaches
what not to do.
It says that particular behavior
is unacceptable.
But a behavior is one
among a panoply of
possible modes of action.
And simply ruling out one of
them doesn't guarantee that
what will replace it is
something prosocial.
So he writes in a very specific
context of fighting,
if you punish your child for
fighting with her brother, it
will indeed stop that fight.
The next time there's a conflict
between them though,
fighting will still be in the
daughter's repertoire, the
default setting.
You haven't done anything
about changing that.
Explaining in words that
fighting is bad won't change
the state of behavior either.
You need to develop another
way of behaving.
You need to promote the positive
opposite to get
another response locked in.
Now the question is whether
there is any possibility of
generalizing this profoundly
correct lesson about what one
does in deeply personal
interactions
to a societal context?
As I pointed out when we read
Plato's Republic, it begins
with the suggestion that if
you want to understand the
structure of the soul, you
need to understand the
structure of society.
And if you want to understand
the structure of society, you
need to understand the structure
of the soul.
In some ways, asking the
apparently absurd question
"does a parenting guide have
anything to teach us about the
criminal justice system?" is
to ask the fundamental
question of Plato's Republic--
does what we do when we engage
in the most intimate and
personal of attempts to
cultivate in others behaviors
that will allow them
to thrive--
does thinking about that teach
us anything about how society
ought to structure its
institutional practices?
And Kazdin gives some indication
that he is thinking
at least implicitly
along those lines.
He writes, "Punishment can
fail for many reasons.
One of them is that reward for
misbehaving is often more
immediate and reliable than
punishment." And goes on to
suggest, not in detail, but just
as a hint, that a look at
the criminal justice
system's normal
operations makes that clear.
If you steal, you get what
you stole right away.
You are therefore reinforced in
a very local sense in the
bad behavior by an
immediate reward.
If you experience a delayed
punishing consequence, that
punishment is doomed to failure
as a method for
changing behavior.
What's required if punishment is
to have a totally deterrent
effect is somehow for the
calculation of the cost of the
punishment to enter in at
the moment of practice.
Kazdin writes, "One must
eliminate the immediate
reinforcer for the punished
behavior if possible, and
that's hard to do."
You'll recall long ago, we had a
picture of Ulysses trying to
get past the sirens.
It was a beautiful 19th century
portrait of Ulysses on
a ship, tied to a mast, with
the rowers beside him, with
their ears blocked.
And that was a slide that we
looked at in the context of
how you overcome immediate
temptation.
And we talked about, in our
discussion of Nozick on
principles and our discussion of
Ariely on procrastination,
what sort of strategies there
are for recalculating or
recalibrating our assessment of
potential immediate payoff.
Thinking about punishment in its
broadest sense gives us a
way of thinking about
that question
from yet another direction.
And, as you'll see, that issue
is going to reemerge very soon
when we start thinking
about Hobbes.
So I leave this puzzle--
or this multi-part puzzle--
for you, as a question.
Punishment illuminated for
us, on the one hand, the
distinction between utilitarian
and deontological
moral theory.
It got us thinking about the
symmetric or asymmetric
relation between praise
and blame.
And it gave us yet another venue
for thinking about the
relation between the personal
and the societal.
So with that, I want to move
to the general topic of
today's lecture.
So the fundamental question of
political legitimacy, as you
know from the brief reading
that you did before the
Hobbes, is the question of why
it is ever legitimate for
there to be such thing
as a state.
It is an astounding fact about
21st century human existence
that of the roughly seven
billion people who live on
this planet at this time, nearly
all of them are subject
to rules and regulations that
are imposed on them by a
governing body--
a government--
as a result simply of their
having been born within the
confines a particular
territory.
It's worth thinking for a moment
about why and perhaps
whether that fact
is legitimate.
And this question--
what makes the state
legitimate--
is the one that we'll address
in the context of this final
unit of the course.
So let's begin by going back to
a passage right before the
one that we focused on so
intently at the beginning of
the term from Plato's
Republic.
So you will remember right
before the discussion of the
ring of Gyges, Glaucon provides
an account of what he
calls the nature and
origins of justice.
And here is what he said.
He says, "They say to do
injustice is naturally good
and to suffer injustice is bad,
but that the badness of
suffering it so far exceeds the
goodness of doing it that
those who have done and suffered
injustice and tasted
both, but who lack the power to
avoid suffering it, decide
that it's profitable to come
to an agreement with each
other to neither do injustice
nor to suffer it."
So the picture is this.
Suppose we have two shepherds.
And the one steals the
other's horses.
From that, he gets pleasure
of say 15.
At the same time, the one
whose horses were stolen
experiences a dissatisfaction,
first 15 at the loss of his
horses and then an additional
displeasure
at having been robbed.
So he turns and steals
the other horses--
sorry, that was supposed to
be more nicely animated.
There we go.
--feeling the pleasure of 15,
where his opponent feels a
displeasure of 25.
So the thought is that both
recognize that in a situation
where stealing is the norm, both
have the potential to end
up worse off than they would
have had they just stuck with
their original property.
As a result, suggests Glaucon,
they come together and they
form some sort of interpersonal
agreement.
Moreover, they institutionalize
it.
As a result says Glaucon, "they
begin to make laws and
covenants and what the law
commands, they call lawful and
just. This," says Glaucon,
'is the origin
and essence of justice.
It is intermediate between the
best and the worst. The best
thing to do injustice without
paying the penalty.
The worst to separate without
being able to take revenge.
Justice this is a mean between
two extremes."
What we have in this 2,000 year
old text is a preliminary
articulation of what has come
to be known as the social
contract tradition in political
philosophy.
This is the view that it is
because in some sense living
in a society structured by laws
is advantageous for all
of us, that the state
is legitimate.
On this picture, what makes it
reasonable that seven billion
people on this planet live their
lives as a result of
having been born in a particular
place under the
auspices of a particular
government, what makes that
legitimate is the fact that as
an aggregate and in fact as
individuals, they are better off
than they would be without
that structure having
been in place.
And that is the fundamental
argument that lies behind the
text that we read from Thomas
Hobbes' Leviathan.
So Hobbes, as you know from
reading the text, lived
roughly at the time
of Shakespeare.
He lived from 1588 to 1679.
So just as he was born,
Shakespeare's first works were
being produced.
And you can see--
sorry, they should stay next to
each other for a moment--
that they wear the
same outfit.
My animation is very
active today.
So, Hobbes was British.
He's best known for his work in
political philosophy, but
he also did work in linguistics
and mathematics.
And it's important to realize as
you think through the ways
in which the text that we read
is extraordinarily systematic,
that Hobbes was highly
influenced by the idea that it
would be possible to derive
very broad principles of
political theory from very
basic facts about human
psychology.
And the idea was to base the
reasoning here on something
like the geometrical method,
where you start with a few
very simple axioms, you have
some rules of derivation, and
from them you can build up
rather elaborate systems. In
particular, Hobbes thought it
would be possible to derive
political philosophy from
thinking about psychology, to
derive psychology from thinking
about physiology, and
to derive physiology from
thinking about physics.
Facts about the physical world
constrained facts about
physiology.
Those in turn constrained
facts about psychology.
And those in turn determined
the nature
all political theory.
So the text that we read for
today is primarily concerned
with these two last stages.
The text we read is from Hobbes'
1651 book Leviathan.
And I reproduced this
frontispiece here because we
are, all of us right now,
sitting about 100 yards from a
copy of this first edition.
And when I taught this class as
a small seminar, one of the
most exciting things that we did
was to take a field trip
to the Beinecke Library and
to see this in person.
And all of you as Yale students
are free to walk over
there and to make an appointment
to look at this.
What's amazing about the
frontispiece is both the
visual imagery on the bottom
and the visual
imagery on the top.
So Hobbes, remember, is
concerned with providing a
philosophical basis to justify
the secular state.
And on the bottom what he has
is a juxtaposition of the
tools of the secular state
with the tools
of religious authority.
So he's talking about the
relation between the castle
and the church, between the
might of weaponry and the
might of religion.
What's relevant for our
discussion here is this
incredible image on the top--
the image of the sovereign
composed of hundreds of
individuals, each of whom has,
on Hobbes' picture of things,
rationally decided to give
up his for her right to
self-authority on certain
questions in order to
guarantee the stability
of society.
So let's ask the question, how
does Hobbes get to this
conclusion?
And what are the fundamental
questions
he's trying to answer?
So, as I said, he starts out
with a discussion simply of
what human reasoning
looks like.
What's our sensory
system like?
How does language allow
us to communicate?
And he goes on from there to
talk about human psychology
and the legitimacy of the state,
concluding with a very
broad discussion of the relation
between the civil
state and religious law.
The questions he's asking are
the questions we're going to
ask for the next
four lectures.
What makes the state
legitimate?
Hobbes' answer is having a
civil state, having civil
society, is the only effective
means of what he calls
commodious self-preservation.
And I'll say a bit about
what that amounts to.
And the second question, what
can we do to guarantee the
stability of the state?
And Hobbes' rather controversial
answer here is
that it's only by means of
putting in place some sort of
absolute sovereign, only by
abdicating a certain amount of
personal freedom, that the
state's continued existence is
guaranteed.
So how does the argument go?
We started our reading for
today with the incredibly
famous passages from Book I,
Chapter 13, of Leviathan,
where Hobbes make the
following argument.
He says, with respect to the
possibility of stealing one
another's property and
potentially taking one
another's lives, human beings
are relatively equal.
They are physically equal in
the sense that each of them
has the live possibility of
killing and of being killed.
And they are mentally equal,
intellectually equal, in the
sense that human beings on the
whole are capable of using
experience to learn how to
navigate their environment.
And in a somewhat coy argument,
he suggests that
everybody thinks himself to be
somewhat clever, and that the
best evidence of rough equality
is that each is
contented with his share.
From this comes the first
premise of the Hobbesian
argument, that when we have this
sort of rough equality in
physical and intellectual
strength, there is an
"equality of hope in attaining
our ends." Everybody can
reasonably expect that
pursuing their own
self-interest will not
necessarily be a futile endeavor.
Since, however, self-interests
conflict--
since, roughly speaking, I want
to get as much as I can
get and you want to get as
much as you can get--
Hobbes suggests that the result
of this rough equality,
this expectation of the
possibility of achieving one's
goals, coupled with the fact
that goals of this sort often
involve taking of property, we
find three sources of conflict
among individuals.
The first Hobbes calls
competition, where the goal is
I want to gain control of stuff
over which you currently
have control.
Note that this use out the
term 'your stuff' at this
point is still metaphorical.
Right.
There's no such thing, says
Hobbes, as property in the
state of nature.
I want to control things
that you control.
And the consequence of that,
says Hobbes, is that I will
engage in violent behavior to
get things that are now under
your control.
The second cause of conflict in
the state of nature is the
preemptive version of this.
The recognition that I want to
keep control of those things
over which I have control, with
the resulting action that
I may preemptively strike to
preserve my possessions.
So the first is simply about
the acquisition of objects.
The second involves an
application of intelligence, a
recognition that someone might
try to acquire things over
which I have control and that
in order to prevent that, I
need to act preemptively.
And the third, says Hobbes, is
this uniquely psychological
feature of human being,
reminding us yet again of our
fundamentally social nature.
And that is what Hobbes
calls glory.
The goal here being
reputation.
I seek your admiration.
And in so doing, I engage in
violence to earn your respect.
Hobbes thinks that in the state
of nature, this sort of
conflict is inevitable.
In particular, when there is
an assumption of rough
equality and an assumption of a
desirous self-interest, the
result will be a war, says
Hobbes, "of every man against
every man." Not necessarily
a hot war in the sense of
violence going on at every
moment, but a recognition that
at any given moment that which
feels secure, might be lost.
And we known from living at a
time when terrorist threat
induces in many of us a feeling
of standing fear, how
dangerous to the psyche it is
to feel that one cannot be
certain or safe in one's
surroundings.
Interestingly, the threat of
things going wrong has almost
as powerful a psychological
effect in anticipation as the
actuality of things
going wrong.
The result of this, says Hobbes,
is that there is no
industry, no culture,
no navigation.
He writes rather poetically, "in
such condition there is no
place for industry because the
fruit thereof is uncertain.
And consequently, there's no
culture of the earth, no
navigation, no use of
commodities that may be
imported by sea, no commodious
buildings, no instruments of
moving and removing such things
as require much force,
no knowledge of the face of the
earth, no account of time,
no arts, no letters, no society,
and what is worst of
all, continual fear and danger
of violent death."
It's important to think about
how many features--
in fact, all the features
of your daily life--
rely on an assumption of a
certain kind of stability, a
certain kind of predictability.
And without that kind of
stability and predictability
says Hobbes, there's
continual fear and
danger of violent death.
And life is, this being the most
famous quote from Hobbes'
Leviathan, --life is "solitary,
poor, nasty,
brutish, and short."
Hobbes goes on to suggest that
this rather unpleasant picture
of human psychological
tendencies that he's painted
in this famous passage is one
which is rather widely shared.
He asks you to think about
whether when you travel, you
lock your doors and whether when
you leave the library,
you bring your computer
with you.
He doesn't ask about the
computer, in those words.
But in pointing out the tendency
of people to protect
themselves with respect to
their property and their
person, he asked "whether you do
not as much accuse mankind
by your actions as," says
Hobbes, "I do by my words."
So that's the beginning
of the argument in
favor of the state.
Rough equality, a tendency to
want what others also want,
and a consequent state of war.
Hobbes steps back for a
minute then and makes
two important caveats.
The first is that he points
out that in order for his
argument to work--
remember his argument is going
to be that the reason it's
legitimate for seven billion
people to be under the
political control of state is
because if they weren't, they
would be worse off.
Hobbes says that argument works
regardless of whether
the state of nature is actually
something that happened.
The argument doesn't turn
on historical fact.
The question, says Hobbes, is
what manner of life there
would be were there no
common power to fear.
And he points out--
so that's the first point
that he makes there.
He then goes on to point out
that most of the things which
we take for granted as part of
how we organize our lives
would be absent without the
existence of social
structures.
The notions of justice and
injustice, says Hobbes, are
social notions.
They depend on there being rules
which can be violated
and some rules which
can be upheld.
Likewise, in exactly the way
that I flipped up four slides
ago, there it is in the state
of nature no notion of
ownership or legal
control as such.
All there is is possession
by force.
So that's the nadir of
Hobbes' argument.
It's really bad news.
It's solitary, poor, nasty,
brutish, and short.
And the question now becomes
what could possibly allow us
to escape from such
a situation?
And Hobbes suggests in the
conclusion of Chapter 13 that
there are three sorts of
motivations that might help
people get out of this
circumstance.
One is a natural
fear of death.
The second is a "desire of such
things as are necessary
for commodious living." Those
are all the sorts of things
that we just talked about.
The things that come only from
predictable possibilities of
cooperation--
buildings, learning,
comfort, stability.
And finally says Hobbes,
there is a hope--
the counterpart of the equality
held with regard to
the state of nature
earlier on--
that "by one's industry," it
would be possible to obtain
those things that are necessary
for commodious
living if only there were stable
circumstances to allow
the efforts to persist.
So we move now to the
fundamental argument of
Hobbes, which involves, in
the excerpts we read, the
derivations of what he calls the
first, second, and third
laws of nature.
So what I want to do first is
to introduce you to Hobbes'
terminology for this.
And then I'm going to give you
the first, second, and third
laws of nature.
And with that we'll
close the lecture.
So Hobbes talks about rights
on the one hand
and laws on the other.
A right of nature, which Hobbes
thinks is fundamental,
and we will hear about this
again when we do our reading
from Robert Nozick for next
Thursday, is the idea
articulated in the founding
documents of the nation in
whose boundaries we now sit,
that each human being is
fundamentally in some
profound sense free.
Each human being has rights,
that Hobbes explicitly calls
inalienable, to engage in
whatever way he or she can to
self-preservation.
That's a fundamental assumption
of Western
political philosophy.
Liberty, on Hobbes' picture,
is a rather narrow notion.
All he means by this is the lack
of external impediment.
Hobbes considers contracts that
are entered into out of
fear to be nonetheless
binding.
The third term that we need from
Hobbes to understand the
rest of the argument is the
idea of a law of nature.
And this is where the trick of
Hobbes' reasoning takes place.
Hobbes says that while it's
true that all of us have
fundamental rights to liberty,
it's also true that there are
things which are binding upon
us as a result of reason.
There are general rules which
reason can lead us to
recognize, that specify what
is forbidden and what is
required to preserve life.
And that once we discover that
these sorts of things are
required to preserve life,
it becomes mandatory
for us to do them.
So the idea of law of nature
is the idea that we can
determine what it would be
that would allow us to
preserve our lives.
And that it then becomes
mandatory for us to do that.
So whereas a right is a kind of
freedom, a law is a kind of
constraint.
So what are the laws of nature
according to Hobbes?
The first law of nature
he derived as follows.
He says, as we know from Chapter
13, that the natural
condition of human beings is
a war of all against all.
But that as we know from the
right of nature, each of us
can do whatever it takes to
preserve ourselves, including
harming others.
The result of this is a lack
of security for all of us.
Once we recognize this, says
Hobbes, reason tells us it is
a general rule of reason that we
are required to "seek peace
if there is a chance
of obtaining peace.
And, if not, to engage
in war."
So the first law of nature,
according to
Hobbes, has two clauses.
It has a peace clause--
a must clause.
If there's a chance of
cooperation, you're required
to do it-- seek peace
and follow it.
And a war clause, which gives
you a permission.
If you cannot have a guarantee
of peace, you may defend
yourself by all means we can
to defend ourselves.
Now, the first law of nature
raises a puzzle because it
asks us what it would take for
there to be a chance of
obtaining peace.
The peace clause only kicks in
if other people are doing the
same thing as you.
And the second law of nature
gives voice to how that first
clause is to be satisfied.
Hobbes says you need to be
willing to lay down your
rights to the extent that others
are willing to do the
same with the aim of promoting
a peaceful state.
You need, says Hobbes, to
"content yourself with as much
liberty against others
as others have
against you." Now.
what we will talk about in the
next lecture is a problem that
arises from this picture.
If other men will not lay down
their right as well as you,
there is no reason for you to
divest yourself of this.
For to do that would be to
expose yourself to prey,
"which no man is bound to,"
rather than to dispose
yourself to peace.
That is the first law of nature
says: Look, without
cooperation, without peace,
life is miserable; it's
solitary, nasty, brutish,
and short--
so self-interest demands that
you seek peace if you can.
The second law of nature tells
you: you should seek peace
insofar as others are
willing to do so.
But the problem that we will
address in the form of the
prisoner's dilemma is that
without some sort of central
coordination, it will always be
rational for everybody to
drop out of the cooperative
situation.
And it's in light of
that Hobbes gives
voice to his solution.
The third law of nature
according to Hobbes is that
you need to perform
your covenants.
That is, you need to do what
you have promised.
And in order for you to do that,
you need to have the
guarantee that others will
also do as they promise.
Covenants, he says, are invalid
if you fear that the
other party may renege.
So to have covenants, there
must be enforcement.
In particular, says Hobbes,
there needs to be some sort of
coercive power that will compel
men equally to the
performance of their covenants,
by the terror of--
I told you punishment
was coming back--
some punishment greater than the
benefit they expect by the
breach of their covenant.
So Hobbes' solution is the
following: He says men
naturally love liberty and
dominion over others, they
recognize that the cost of
this is the miserable
condition of war.
The only means of getting
themselves out of this is
through the introduction of a
restraint among themselves in
the form of a commonwealth.
And because we are unlike ants
and bees, cooperation can't be
achieved without this
external constraint.
Conclusion, says Hobbes, is
that each of us must say,
hypothetically and voluntarily,
"I authorize and
give up my right of governing
myself to this man or to this
assembly of men on this
condition that thou give up
thy right to him and authorize
his actions in like manner."
That is, says Hobbes, it is
only when individuals form
themselves into a society
whereby in return for giving
up freedom, commodious
living is possible.
It's only then that most of
the things that we take as
definitive of human society
and human experience even
become possible.
What we'll look at next lecture
is a schema for
thinking about the dilemma that
Hobbes thinks we find
ourselves in, and ask whether
Hobbes' solution, the
imposition of an external
sovereign, is indeed the only
solution to the puzzle which he
poses to us in the form all
his argument about the state
of nature, the first and
second laws of nature,
and finally the
third law of nature.
So I'll see everyone
on Thursday.